sad news out of Georgia this morning
we're a top prospect in this year's NFL
Draft faces criminal charges we're
talking about Georgia Bulldog star
defensive lineman Jalen Carter who
turned himself in overnight after being
charged with reckless driving and racing
all tied to a January 15th car crash
that killed his teammate Devin Willock
and recruiting staff member Chandler
Lacroix Mannie bojorquez is in Athens
Georgia this is where Carter was booked
and then released Manny it's a sad story
on multiple levels good morning
good morning that crash happened hours
after Georgia's national championship
parade here in Athens initially reported
as a single vehicle accident police now
say Carter was racing against one of the
victims
according to an arrest warrant Jalen
Carter and Chandler Lacroix were driving
in a manner consistent with racing at
about 2 30 a.m evidence showed both
vehicles switched between lanes drove in
the opposite Lanes of travel and drove
speeds over 100 miles per hour Lacroix
struck two power poles and several trees
with Willock riding as a passenger both
died from their injuries Carter
allegedly told investigators he wasn't
there at the time of the crash and in a
statement yesterday he wrote there is no
question in my mind that when all of the
facts are known that I will be fully
exonerated of any criminal wrongdoing
he's someone who's projected to be one
of the top picks in the NFL draft and
we'll see if he still will be Seth
Emerson is a senior Rider at the
athletic covering Georgia football he
says Carter is one of the best defensive
players Georgia's had in recent years
it's going to be a matter I think of a
lot of NFL teams deciding how much risks
tolerance they can have to this
situation it's going to cause them to do
a lot more due diligence on Jalen Carter
and look into his background and see if
there's anything there the January
accident has shaken the Athens campus
yesterday linebacker Nolan Smith NFL
bound himself spoke for the first time
about his Fallen teammate Devin Willock
just before the news broke about Carter
and I get sensitive talking about it
just because I love him
you know he never did anything wrong in
his three years he was supposed to
graduate most people don't know his
his brother passed like that no one
should deserve to die like that
and Georgia coach Kirby Smart said the
school is cooperating with the
investigation he called the Chargers
quote deeply concerning if convicted of
the two misdemeanor charges Carter could
face up to two years in prison flap
Manny thank you very much as you said
Tony it's a terrible situation all
around car goes out to the families of
those who died yes and this young man's
life is potentially ruined it's people
on the on the brink of their dream
whether your dream is graduating college
or playing in the NFL you're on the edge
of it and to have this happen it's just
tragic tragic no and they're all
celebrating and you know when you're
young you do you can do stupid
knucklehead things like that you just
hope that when it happens it's not
something that's irreparable this is
irreparable irreparable because two
people have lost their lives exactly